[Music]
sarah in
idaho hi sarah welcome to dave ramsey
show
hi i question about retirement that you
guys were talking about in investments
um so my husband and i are on track to
finish baby step to the end of this year
and we've been looking forward to in vet
investment um
i had a question if it's a better deal
to be able to
just invest a lump sum like the
beginning of each year instead of
monthly
i was able to come up with like 5500
for each of us beginning of the year
well you've got it you've either got it
invested all year or you've got it
invested 11 months 10 months eight
months nine months
five months so assuming the investment
is good the
on average it's going to be better to
lump sum it mathematically
now sometimes people suggest you do
gradually
dollar cost averaging so you get some
expensive shares some cheaper shares and
all that throughout the year
that does not come out to be more money
but what it does do
is it does indicate that steady
constant investing is really the answer
not just flash in the pan investing
and the second thing is that you don't
have any emotional problems
meaning if you turn on the news which
i've just about quit doing
um and uh because it's just stupid
but the uh but anyway if you turn on the
news and they're screaming
uh you know that the stock market has
crashed and
four days before you put all your money
in
and then you go oh the market's down
they never talk about they never come on
and go hey everybody
the market was really up today they
never do that right
but they're going to scream and yell and
flop in the floor foam at the mouth all
this stuff
when it goes down if you can't
emotionally handle the roller coaster
ride
four days later then don't lump summit
that's right and sarah
hear me out i love that you're asking an
investing question that tickles my heart
but you're on baby step two you guys are
about to wrap that up
you are not going to at the beginning of
the year invest at the beginning of the
year you guys are gonna start your fully
funded emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses then
you'll shift
to investing and so that's that's the
mindset around it and again i love that
people get excited and
matter of fact kelly if you'll get her
uh information i'll send her my book
retire inspired
because it's good to have that
information but don't mess with the
recipe
follow the steps